I've had a few questions about whether I
still hang out with Orlando Bloom he
said I used to have to point out that
when Orlando and I were working together
he was 19 and I was about 55 or
something like that and you should worry
a little bit if a 55 year old man is
hanging out with it a lot a 19 year old
fence but a lot of questions about
whether we still keep in touch most of
us are still busy working actors spread
out around the world so so we don't
really sort of keep that in touch but I
did have a nice email from Vigo the
other day and I you know I beeped look I
I bump into them from time to time
generally in conventions things like
that so we do catch up from time to time
it was a massive undertaking making
those films wasn't it wasn't like as an
actor involved in those star trilogy
well I knew very early on probably
before some of the others that what we
were doing was going to make cinema
history so the you there is that part of
it but part of the fun of being an
actress is the time you spend with your
fellow actors and the very nature of my
makeup and the need to preserve my
makeup and the fact that I was too large
really to give them an eyeline when they
were working on camera so you know they
I had a I had a double who would sit in
front of the camera before them
and they would they would talk to him
and then at the end of the day I'd they
cut me into two doing this as well so it
was a very lonely existence incidentally
I noticed that Ian McKellen was saying
because he was now being treated to the
new the new processes where you can you
can dial in the proportions all of the
CAG but it meant that he had to be in a
separate room separate studio with the
action going on and he he commented that
it was desperately lonely because the
most fun is is is dishing the dirt with
your fellow actors really did you
particularly enjoy then at the end of a
long hard day working on set getting to
actually see some people
well yes but then I go you know took me
took me an hour to get the darn stuff
off hey and it you know and then it was
removing so much of my skin that you
know I looked I looked so hideous you
know you're you're in you're in a bad
way when your then girlfriend turns
round to you and says you know
sweetheart I don't know how to say this
but I can't bear to look at you anymore
I've got to go back to LA but I really
was looking absolutely hideous did you
oh you just wet meat all around there
you know
and of course the swelling and the sort
of the slightly solid yucky skin
complaint solemn it was just wet needs
there was it like being in New Zealand
Oh New Zealand Bay I loved New Zealand
yeah great place I went back to do a
convention much like this in 2004 and to
promote it I went on TV one in New
Zealand and I was introduced interviewed
by a lady called Lisa Manning who was
hosting the show good morning and she
came to the show and I took her out to
dinner and two years later we have a
baby we had a baby daughter who is
coming up for seven I've got a sort of
measure of real affection for New
Zealand why do you think it's also loved
today those Tolkien books and also the
films are so held dear to people's
hearts on though the films are I think
probably the greatest achievement of
modern cinema I don't I don't speak this
lightly the books are unfilmable it is
not only to Peter Jackson Jackson's
credit that he found a way of filming
them definitively and astonishingly but
he built an entire film industry in New
Zealand to service them his achievement
is one of the most remarkable
achievements of any producer director of
all time
just just amazing well deserved
knighthood
as for the books in every bookshelf in
every bookshop in any country of the
world there is about two feet of
bookshelf devoted to talking is a
remarkable man he's a happy man I think
he is loved by his students by his
family by his colleagues talking has it
all because he gets it right you know
he's a man who can survive World War one
knowing that knowing why he was fighting
a lot of people in the end lost the
sight of why they were fighting and he
was he was a moral man and and
understood that great stories are moral
moral tales they're about good and evil
you